2000 condamnation par an nous devons
progresser de deux manières la première
c'est par la loi et ensuite progresser
parce que nous appelons des pratiques
professionnelles protectrice la justice
à sa part dans cette impunité
comment souhaitez vous la faire évoluer
nous devons être concret pour que la
protection ne soit pas un mot mais une
réalité
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
je suis les chômeurs et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 9 juin faire
savoir clairement à poutine et à la
chine que les états unis et l'europe
sont soudés c'est en ces termes que joe
biden a défini le but de son voyage en
europe juste avant de s'envoler vers
londres premier déplacement officiel du
président américain depuis son arrivée à
la maison blanche le royaume uni dron
point de départ de sa tournée européenne
à l'occasion du g7 qui le conduira
jusqu'à genève où il doit rencontrer le
président russe la semaine prochaine
un nouveau parfum de liberté souffre sur
la faune souffle sur la france nouvelle
étape du déconfinement aujourd'hui avec
un pauvre feu dès qu'elle est à 23
heures réouverture des salles de sport
restaurant retour des festivals
également mais aussi nouveauté de cette
troisième étape le passe à lutter pour
accéder à certains lieux et événements
plus de 1000 personnes notamment qui
fait parfois d'ailleurs grincer des
dents l'état condamné pour faute lourde
les faits remontent à 2010 cette gare du
nord à paris trois lycéens estimé avoir
été victime de contrôles
discriminatoires au retour d'un voyage
scolaire à bruxelles devant leurs
classes et des passants la cour d'appel
de paris leur a donné raison et a
condamné l'état à payer 1500 euros en
réparation préjudice moral pour chaque
jeune
[Musique]
près de cinq mois après son arrivée au
pouvoir le président américain joe biden
s'est donc envolé pour le royaume-uni
première étape d'une tournée européenne
avec de nombreuses rencontres
bilatérales qui s'achèvera par un sommet
avec les lumières poutine le 16 juin
pour plus de précisions nous retrouvons
tout de suite notre reporter thomas
bonnet en direct de washington est
thomas concevoir joe biden qui se
rendent ou encore d'europe pour son
premier voyage officiel en tant que
président des états unis à quoi doit-on
s'attendre à wimbledon est parti ce
matin heure de washington donc en
direction du royaume uni où il devrait
arriver dans le courant de la soirée
vous l'avez dit il va y avoir un certain
nombre de rencontres notamment en
premier lieu avec le premier ministre
britannique boris johnson mais aussi la
reine d'angleterre ce sera ce week-end
il ya surtout des sommets importants le
sommet du g7 et le sommet de l'otan qui
aura lieu lui à bruxelles avant
finalement évidemment la rencontre avec
vladimir poutine à genève le 16 juin une
rencontre jugée comme très importante
par la maison blanche et par joe biden
qui a été interrogé juste avant de
prendre l'avion je propose d'écouter
renforcer l'alliance faire savoir
clairement à poutine et à la chine que
les états unis et l'europe sont soudés
et que le g7 va avancer
pensez vous que poutine va trouver un
accord avec vous sur les cyberattaques
qui sait
ce sera un sujet de nos discussions
alors je m'adonne l'a dit et l'a répété
il veut renouer de bonnes relations avec
les alliés européens et veut essayer de
prouver en quelque sorte que les états
unis sont de nouveau en interlocuteur
fiable et il faut dire qu'en face les
pays de l'union européenne sont plutôt
inquiet par la fragilité de la politique
américaine il ya surtout un certain
nombre de points de désaccord sur lequel
il va falloir s'entendre lors de sept de
ce voyage
d'abord il ya la position sur la chine
puisque les etats-unis souhaiteraient
que l'europe s'aligne sur la position
qui est la leur une position plutôt
agressive mais cela va à l'encontre des
intérêts de plusieurs pays européens
tels que l'allemagne puisqu'on sait
berlin a des liens commerciaux très fort
avec un péquin autres points d accord c
la distribution du vaccin ya beaucoup de
pays de membres de l'union européenne
qui reproche aux états unis d'avoir
tardé avant de produire des vaccins à
destination du monde entier à travers le
programme kovacs alors on a appris il ya
quelques instants que les états unis
allaient acheter des centaines de
millions de vaccins à pfizer pour
ensuite les distribuer c'est donc un pas
a semble-t-il qui est fait en direction
des pays européens
et puis il ya un autre dossier aussi qui
va devoir être abordés il s'agit de
l'ouverture des voyages pour l'épée les
pays entre les pays entre les deux
continents entre les européens et les
américains n'y a pas encore de
réciprocité sur l'ouverture des
frontières et puis il faut rappeler
enfin qu'il ya quelques jours à peine
de nouvelles révélations ont été faites
au danemark sur les écoutes de la nsa
sur des dirigeants européens là encore
ça ne participe pas vraiment à la bonne
entente entre joe biden et c'est un
homme interlocuteurs européens
on surveillera aussi avec attention la
date de la teneur des discussions entre
joe biden et boris johnson puisqu'on le
sait le premier ministre britannique
était plutôt un proche de donald trump
et de son côté joe biden lui s'est
montré très intransigeant avec la
question de la frontière nord irlandaise
en en faisant une condition à la
conclusion d'un accord entre les
etats-unis et le royaume-uni
alors il ya quand même un point d'accord
possible voire même probable puisque
selon les informations de bloomberg un
communiqué conjoint pourraient être
dévoilés à cette semaine entre les pays
membres de l'union européenne et les
unis un communiqué qu' exhorterait de
manière formelle à de nouvelles
investigations sur l'origine du coc vite
19 en tout cas pour son premier voyage
officiel joe biden a choisi l'europe et
c'est évidemment tout sauf un hasard
c'est un symbole qu'il veut adresser à
ses alliés européens
un mot enfin pour vous dire que joe
biden ne sera pas seul lors de ce voyage
il est accompagné de sa femme jill elle
va profiter pour sa part de ce
déplacement pour rencontrer des vétérans
et leurs familles
thomas quel regard porte la presse
américaine sur ce premier déplacement
officiel du président américain
beaucoup de médias américains souligne
le timing de ce déplacement parce
qu'abidal est en difficulté dans les
affaires internes américaine en ce
moment il faut dire qu'il fait face à un
obstacle de taille puisqu'il n'y a pas
eu d'accord concernant un plan très
ambitieux qui l'a lancé de 2200
milliards de dollars d'investissements
pour entre autres rénovés de nombreuses
infrastructures aux états unis ils
voulaient pour cela augmenter les taxes
sur les une société ils s'opposent il
s'est vu opposer le refus des sénateurs
républicaine est donc une sorte
d'impasse politique
d'où cette question est ce le bon moment
pour lui de voyager non répondent
certains car il ya des interrogations
sur qui va justement gérer les affaires
internes en son absence alors la porte
parole de la maison blanche s'est voulu
rassurant en expliquant que
l'administration était prête pour cela
et qu'abidal suivra de toute façon les
dossiers à distance et puis il ya
d'autres personnes qui disent que c'est
le bon moment justement pour joe biden
de quitter les états unis car il revient
en quelque sorte à ses premières amours
il a été un vice président qui était
très porté sur l'international lorsqu'il
était donc le vice-président de barack
obama il avait fait beaucoup de
déplacements à l'époque mais cette fois
ci il est dans le rôle du président des
états unis est donc dans le rôle du
décideur ce qui change pas mal de choses
et que ce soit avec les alliés de l'otan
avec les pays membres de l'union
européenne ou encore avec vladimir
poutine
il y aura beaucoup de dossiers abordés
sans doute des discussions très animées
pour je ride
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington et pour parler de cette
tournée européenne du président
américain
nous sommes avec l claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir claude
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous
qu'est-ce que dubaï donne attend de ce
g7 qui débutera vendredi
objectif principal c'est évidemment de
réaffirmer le leadership américain et
dans le fond ça ne sera pas si simple
que cela puisque donald trump avait
horreur de ce genre de réunions qu'ils
soient se passer balle soit le voyez
relativement discret comme à biarritz
lorsque la france présidé le g7 et
l'année dernière il a carrément passer
son tour
c'était aux états unis de présider un g7
et après avoir proposé de le tenir à
marée de la gauche c'est-à-dire chez lui
près de son terrain de golf puis à quand
des villes il a dû renoncer la
chancelière ayant dit que le coc vie de
finalement faisait qu' elles ne
pourraient pas se déplacer les eaux qui
lui faut réaffirmer son leadership et
pour cela il va d'abord prendre des
moyens qui sont des sujets consensuels
naturellement le réchauffement
climatique puisqu'il a réintroduit les
états unis dans l'accord de paris et
qu'il est sincèrement convaincu qu'il
faut en effet lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique
il en va de l'avenir de la planète et
puis la vaccination alors il va il va
certainement affirmé qu' il faut
maintenant vaccinée le monde évidemment
ces nouveaux puisque comme d'autres pays
l'a d'ailleurs donner la priorité à ses
compatriotes aux américains et tous les
vaccins fabriqués sur le territoire
américain ont été consacrés à la
vaccination des américains donc
aujourd'hui et il commence à prendre des
mesures pour à travers le dispositif de
l' oms de donner des vaccins de faire en
sorte que les pays les plus pauvres
puissent disposer de vaccins pour le
moment les engagements les états unis
sont inférieurs à ceux de l'union
européenne et pour vacciner la terre
entière il faudrait évidemment les
milliards de vaccins qui pour le moment
ne peuvent pas être produit car il n'y a
pas des capacités industrielles dans le
monde
donc peut-être discuterons t-il de cela
comment faire pour faire en sorte que de
développer ses capacités industrielles
et monter des task force pour ce que en
effet les vaccins soient disponibles
pour tout le monde c'est d'ailleurs à
cette seule condition
que la pandémie s'arrêtera je pense
qu'il prendra aussi oui je pense qu'il
essaiera aussi de renforcer ce que les
ministres des finances du g7 ont discuté
au congrès ont conclu un accord dimanche
dernier c'est en effet une novation
considérable puisqu'il s'agirait de
taxer les grandes multinationales qui
pour le moment peuvent localiser leurs
bénéfices un peu là où elles le veulent
et évidemment optimiser leur leurs
paiements fiscaux c'est-à-dire les
minimiser en réalité donc si le g7
confirme ce que lemmy des finances ont
conclu eh bien il faudra ensuite
convaincre le g20
ensuite convaincre l'ouest celle ocde et
ensuite effectivement mettre en place ce
dispositif
ça ne sera pas très simple mais c'est
courageux de sa part de vouloir essayer
en tout cas on reste avec vous claude
blanchou maison pour continuer à évoquer
en ce déplacement ô combien important
puisqu'on l'a dit sera ponctuée de
beaucoup de deux rencontres bilatérales
au menu un notamment des discussions
également de cette tournée européenne du
président américain la construction du
gazoduc nord stream 2 qui continue
d'inquiéter l'europe et les états unis
washington et berlin annonce d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui vouloir coopérer afin de
sauvegarder les droits de transit
ukrainien menacé par à la mise en place
du gazoduc
de son côté moscou se dit prêt à
discuter avec l'ukraine et invite
l'union européenne à prendre ses
responsabilités vis-à-vis de son
partenaire ukrainien je vous propose
d'écouter sergueï lavrov ministre russe
des affaires étrangères
plutôt que de l'histoire concernant le
nord stream 2 n'est pas terminée chaud
[Musique]
j'ai lu les nouveaux commentaires de
monsieur blinken selon lesquelles les
états unis étudier des moyens de
maintenir les droits de transit
ukrainien pour les livraisons de gaz
vers l'union européenne nous avons un
accord de transit avec l'ukraine pour la
période allant jusqu'à l'année 2024
il reste à discuter de la suite mais dès
maintenant l'administration américaine
souhaite éviter que l'ukraine ne souffre
du muscle oblique
selon monsieur blinken une des solutions
est de prolonger l'accord de transit
pour de nombreuses années à venir pour
que l'ukraine touche des droits de
transit ou une autre solution si la
première ne marche pas consiste à
trouver un moyen de compenser les pertes
financières à kiev
c'est ce dont les européens devront
s'occuper de nous il est toujours avec
nous donc claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales
claude
bon gré mal gré le projet de ce gazoduc
1 hors stream 2 va donc voir le jour
pourquoi les etats-unis ont-ils
finalement changé de position il n'y a
que de bonnes nouvelles en ce qui
concerne le nord stream 2 puisque en
effet le 19 mai l'administration
américaine a décidé de lever les
sanctions qui s'appliquait à l'égard de
l'entreprise qui construit les north
stream 2 et à partir de ce moment les
travaux ont pu reprendre pendant le
forum de saint pétersbourg
il a été annoncé que la première ligne
de nord stream ii était achevée que les
travaux sur la deuxième ligne se
poursuivaient il serait achevée dans
trois mois donc en effet c'est la
chancelière merkel qui l'a emporté avec
son calme et sa détermination habituelle
puisque 100 employés de grands mots est
là avec une grande constance développer
son argumentation
vis-à-vis de ses partenaires de l'union
européenne et vis-à-vis des américains
et finalement elle l'a emporté son
argumentation est très simple
l'allemagne a renoncé au nucléaire pour
fabriquer l'électricité elle s'est
engagée à renoncer au charbon et à
décarbonés complètement son industrie
par conséquent et il n'y aura plus de
deux centrales à charbon en 2038
les énergies renouvelables ne suffiront
pas à combler le déficit il faut donc du
gaz
et effectivement c'est assez logique de
prendre du gaz russe puisque c'est sur
le même continent il peut être amené à
boncourt à bon prix par des
infrastructures fixes et coûter moins
cher par conséquent que le gaz liquéfié
qui viendrait des états unis d'amérique
ou ou d'ailleurs où le golfe et par
conséquent c'est ce qui va se produire
alors bien entendu on a toujours dit et
beaucoup de pays ont toujours dit qu'il
fallait garantir les recettes que le
transit au curé à l'ukraine puisqu'il ya
un gazoduc qui continuera de fonctionner
bien sûr il n'est pas question de le
remplacer qui traversent l'ukraine et il
faut qu'ils aient une discussion
donc comme l'a dit monsieur lavrov il y
a une obligation maintenant de discuter
entre la russie
les européens et l'ukraine et tant mieux
puisque plus on discutera entre ses
pattes
ces trois partenaires mieux ça vaudra
vous restez avec nous encore une fois
que la blanche maison puisque avant de
s'envoler à un joe biden a précisé que
le but de son voyage était de faire
savoir clairement à poutine et à la
chine que les états unis et l'europe
sont sud est soudé on l'a entendu
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure sur le tarmac
à taiwan et d'ailleurs aucun de ces
tensions entre la chine et les états
unis le sénat américain qui vient de
voter un plan historique
d'investissement de 250 milliards de
dollars avec lille objectif contrer des
menaces présumées de la chine sur le
détroit de formose
de son côté pékin dénonce la paranoïa
washington qui multiplient les contacts
diplomatiques avec taipei hélène
masquelier trois sénateurs américains
sur le tarmac de taipei ce dimanche
c'est la deuxième délégation américaine
à se rendre dans le détroit de formose
en à peine un mois
le but officiel de l'expédition un don
de vaccins washington promet la
distribution de 750 mille doses à l'île
confrontée à une soudaine flambée de
covile 19 oui nous sommes ici en ami car
nous savons que taiwan fait actuellement
face à des difficultés
ce qui explique l'importance de notre
visite à tous les trois issus des deux
partis
une visite amicale est plus qu'une
promenade de santé
les élus américains arrivés à bord d'un
avion militaire lancé un message à pékin
washington se dit inquiet face à la
multiplication des incursions chinoise
dans l'espace aérien de l'île le
rapprochement avec taiwan est bel et
bien amorcée
les etats-unis ont annoncé ce lundi la
préparation d'un accord commercial
d'ampleur présenté comme un texte
historique pour contrer la menace
économique de la chine je sais que nous
avons des discussions avec taïwan ou que
nous allons en entamer bientôt sous une
forme d'accords cadres ces discussions
devraient commencer taiwan doit avoir
les moyens de se défendre a également
affirmé
le chef de la diplomatie américaine
washington qui a rompu ses relations
diplomatiques avec taipei en 1979
reconnaissant ainsi pékin comme seuls
représentants officiels de la chine mais
les états unis reste l'allié le plus
puissant de taiwan est son premier
fournisseur d'armes
ce nouveau rapprochement est perçu par
pékin comme une provocation aux mains de
m nous demandons aux états unis
d'appliquer immédiatement le principe
d'une seule chine et les dispositions
des trois communiqués conjoints chine
etats unis de cesser toute forme des
changes officielles avec taiwan de
traiter la question de taiwan avec
prudence et de s'abstenir d'envoyer des
signaux erronés aux forces
indépendantistes de taiwan taiwan un
sujet hautement sensible pour la chine
est un dossier prioritaire pour le
président américain
dès sa prestation de serment le 20
janvier
joe biden avait exprimé sa détermination
à renforcer les relations avec le
détroit de formose allant jusqu'à
inviter la représentante de taiwan aux
états unis à la cérémonie
cette nouvelle visite diplomatique
contribue ainsi à attiser les tensions
entre les deux pays
au risque de brouiller un peu plus la
limite entre compétition économique et
risque de confrontation militaire et
club blanchemaison vont retrouver pour
la dernière fois pour évoquer un tour
tous ces thèmes qui ponctuent qui vont
ponctuer cette tournée américaine la
première de joe biden le sénat américain
donc adopté hier un texte qualifié
d'historique pour contrer pékin des
états unis ne vont pas s'arrêter là
je crois que le texte en effet adopté
par le congrès est très important 170
milliards de dollars pour la recherche
la recherche
fondamentale la recherche appliquée et
pour éviter que que la chine presse une
aide prennent une avance déterminante
sur les dents les nouvelles technologies
je crois que d'ailleurs que l'europe
ferait bien de s'inspirer de cet exemple
cela dit monsieur byden a souvent dit et
les américains disent depuis un certain
temps sont pas nécessaires le disait
aussi que la chine est beaucoup plus
qu'un concurrent
c'est un rival systémique c'est à dire
que le système chinois est antinomique
des systèmes américain et settat rival
systémique qui en plus a des velléités
de contrôler les zones de trafic
maritime
que ce soit à l'est de la chine entre la
chine et le japon
que ce soit en asie du sud-est c'est ce
qu'on appelle la mer de chine du sud
et puis évidemment dans le détroit de
taiwan et vous venez vous venez d'en
parler là il ya évidemment pour tous les
pays occidentaux d'ailleurs un élément
tout à fait essentiel le maintien de la
liberté de navigation dans tout cédé 3
et dans toutes ces mères puisqu'une
grande partie du trafic de marchandises
du monde entier passent par ces détroit
et par saison
donc je crois que en effet les états
unis ont entrepris d'utiliser sans doute
taïwan comme contrepoids réchauffer
leurs relations avec taiwan de façon à à
dire à la chine attention mais il ya une
limite c'est celle que vous avez
indiquée dans votre sujet tous les pays
qui ont des relations diplomatiques avec
pékin ont reconnu qu'il n'y avait qu'une
seule chine et qu'il ne pouvait pas
avoir de relations diplomatiques avec
taipei peuvent entretenir des relations
économiques et des relations culturelles
les etats-unis traditionnellement et se
considère comme responsable de la
défense de taiwan
mais il ya une ligne à ne pas dépasser
sinon effectivement pékin ne
l'accepterai pas alors ce sujet va sans
doute être adopté et être évoqué au g7
une bonne surprise il a été ménagé à
monsieur byden c'est que le deuxième
jour il va trouver autour de la table
les invités
monsieur votre jeune soeur de monsieur
boris johnson qui sont le premier
ministre indien qui sont le premier le
président sud coréen
le premier ministre australien est
également le président sud africain
ces quatre pays font partie de ce que
les think tanks américains appellent une
éventuelle initiative indo pacifique
c'est à dire une ceinture plus ou moins
formalisées qui serait destiné à
contenir la chine
d'ailleurs il y à quelques quelques
semaines et environ deux mois le
président by dell avait pris
l'initiative d'un sommet entre lui même
et certains des dirigeants de ce pays le
premier ministre japonais le premier
ministre indien est le premier ministre
australien
il ya donc en effet là quelque chose qui
probablement va provoquer une discussion
eau pendant pendant le pendant le g7
discussions sur la façon la meilleure
façon de prendre le problème chinois
avec ces pays ces pays ne sont pas tous
désireux d'avoir une alliance formalisé
l'inde par exemple est très très très
très heureux sans doute d'avoir deux des
relations plus fortes avec les états
unis mais elle ne veut pas d'une
alliance militaire quelle règle veut
conserver les bonnes relations avec la
chine
et il en va de même d'ailleurs de la
corée du sud
il veut pas aggraver les tensions avec
la corée du nord par ailleurs les
américains ont fait savoir déjà dans le
passé
il comptait sur d'autres pays qui ne
sont pas particulièrement démocratique
pour contenir la chine par exemple
vietnam
donc il est probable que ce concept se
vendent au pacifique est encore assez
floue se précisera peut-être sous
diverses formes dans l'est dans l'est
dans les mois et dans les années à venir
merci claude blanchemaison et le royaume
uni dont point de départ de cette
tournée du président américain alors que
la relation dite spéciale est souvent
vantée est-ce toujours le cas
aujourd'hui spécial ou pas boris johnson
et joe biden se rencontreront pour la
première fois et ce dans un contexte
inédit post préc site pour en parler
nous sommes en direct depuis londres
avec un martin mc cully un ellis
politique c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir martin mc cully merci d'être
avec nous alors pourquoi de joe biden et
il choisit le royaume uni pour son
premier déplacement à l'étranger
un jeu pour place du bail
il est très important pour le président
peyton du royaume uni car il a beaucoup
de problèmes
c'est un taux d'approbation très élevé
dans de nombreux pays d'europe donc il
faut il veut faire une bonne impression
il se rend donc au royaume uni pour
rencontrer borussen sonne il veut
prendre l'initiative et dire à boris
johnson qu'il doit résoudre le problème
irlandais cette frontière entre la mer
d'irlande entre l'irlande du nord et le
royaume uni
car cela sape les accords du vendredi
saint
c'est très important et du fait de son
origine de leçons origines familiales et
il a un droit à s'exprimer très
important et il doit dire à bord est sûr
c'est qu'il doit résoudre ce problème
blanche les boris johnson ne peut pas
résoudre le problème tout seul
la france tu dis que l'union européenne
ne répond pas aux initiatives
britannique
ils demandent à l'union européenne
d'accepter des compromis afin d'avancer
les deux côtés doivent trouver des
compromis et boris johnson expliquera à
cela au président byden lorsqu'ils se
rencontreront à londres alors ont
toujours cette relation spéciale entre
le royaume uni et les etats unis est ce
toujours le cas on sait en tout cas pour
ce qui concerne cette relation entre les
deux hommes que joe biden était pas
nécessairement le choix de boris johnson
qui s'entendent plutôt bien avec donald
trump plus de gens le président entrant
avait une relation spéciale avec le
royaume uni il avait même acheté un golf
en écosse la relation avec le président
de maiden est différente car
il est d'origine irlandaise et l'irlande
a été très longtemps une colonie
britannique à colonie anglaise d'accord
donc il faut garder cela à l'esprit n'y
a pas la même relation instinctive avec
londres avec l'angleterre que donald
trump
mais joe biden c'est qu'il est très
important pour les etats-unis de
développer le multilatéralisme et cela
passe par développer de bonnes relations
avec le royaume uni s'assurer que le
royaume uni et les etats unis tombent
d'accord sur les grands problèmes
internationaux l'union européenne est
également importante
l'occident en général est important jo
d'athènes a dit que l'occident devrait
se rassembler afin se fédérer afin de
défendre ses intérêts contre la chine
l'intérêt principal pour joe biden à
londres
et lorsqu'il se rendra en europe et de
forger des alliances encourager la
compréhension
sachant que les états unis travailleront
avec l'union européenne avec l'oreille
une mi temps la poursuite de leurs
intérêts communs afin de lutter contre
l'expansionnisme chinois alors le
royaume uni ayant quitté l'union
européenne on précise d'ailleurs que joe
biden était contraint ce bric site est
ce que c'est maintenant l'occasion
d'être pragmatique et d'en faire un
partenaire commercial privilégié lui
aimerait avoir une relation spéciale
notamment une relation spéciale
économiques avec les états unis ue
le président traite aurait bien aimé
avoir un accord entre les etats-unis et
le royaume-uni ou entre les états unis
et
allemagne mais l'union européenne qui
agissait en tant qu'union a empêché d'un
train de créer des accords pap y est on
peut considérer que les états unis que
le l'union européenne n'est pas assez
conciliants concernant cette frontière
irlandaise et boris johnson va sans
doute demander à dubaï terme d'utiliser
son influence à bruxelles afin de faire
avancer la situation car il faut
résoudre ce problème
cette barrière de la mer d'irlande
handicap
les relations entre le royaume uni et
l'irlande
il faut que cette situation soit résolue
avant de former une relation commerciale
spéciale entre les états unis et le
royaume uni merci beaucoup martin mc caw
les analystes politiques d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt français
d'avoir évoqué donc cette première étape
de la tournée de joe biden qui va
atterrir dans la soirée à londres là où
vous vous trouvez elle rester avec nous
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur la troisième étape du déconfinement
enclenché aujourd'hui en france avec un
pauvre hoffer repoussée à 23 heures mais
aussi l'entrée en vigueur du pass annie
terre qui nous évoquerons la
condamnation de l'état pour faute lourde
après le contrôle au faciès subies par
trois lycéens en 2010 cette gare du nord
à paris
[Musique]
en féminicide et commis tous les deux à
trois jours en france actuellement
pourquoi il joue ton encore à protéger
totalement les femmes on dit souvent
femmes osé en parler
briser le silence nous savons que
seulement 18 19 % des femmes révèle les
violences qu'elles subissent donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya 80% de femmes qui ne
révèle pas les violences qu'elles
subissent aux forces de sécurité
donc celle qui rêvait il faut vraiment
les croix et les protéger souvent on met
toute la responsabilité sur la victime
c'est la question de quels sont les
moyens que l'agresseur a mis en oeuvre
qui doit être posée et la loi le dis
très clairement
et souvent on détourne la loi par cette
histoire de consentement on voit bien
qu'on est quand même encore très loin
très loin de ce qui est nécessaire pour
vraiment pouvoir avoir les moyens de
protéger les femmes
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'on nous trouve la
table c'était une volonté collectés vous
le savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il
n'y a pas d'alternative on sort du
politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
sable est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inusité gilet jaune c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était les gens qui travaillent ces
gens qui avaient envie de transmettre
quelque chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit qui doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la doublette
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux ans et demi plus tard vous vous
imposez comme un espoir français du
tennis fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris y sommes le sport
m'a toujours sauver le tennis c'est que
c'est mon sport
bon il ya un fauteuil mais je vais
essayer en fait je me suis rendu compte
que ça allait c'était suffisamment
physique pour moi j'ai une vie de
sportif de haut niveau je m'entraîne
tous les jours c'est devenu ma vie la
raison de me lever le matin j'avais
toujours ce vieux rêve de petite fille
de faire du sport de ma vie est
finalement là c'est c'est ce que je
réalise avec les gens vont manger un
autre combat ma vie qui est celui de la
sécurité routière s'agit d'un projet de
loi qui vise à mettre en place des tests
d'aptitude pour tous les conducteurs pas
seulement les seniors on a un contrôle
technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit re doit
imposer loi sur ce sujet là
[Musique]
bienvenue sur la défense si vous nous
rejoignez en direct phase iii du
déconfinement france lé retour à la vie
d'avant continue de prendre forme avant
un déconfinement total le 30 juin
si la situation sanitaire le permet bien
évidemment
pour plus de précisions on retrouve
quatre siaap technique katia parfum de
liberté qui souffle dans les rues de
paris je dois dire qu'on vous envie ce
soir n'est ce pas ça change de la plus
parisienne
mais oui en effet évidemment les
promeneurs tout le monde est très
content que tout rouvre enfin
partiellement en tout cas c'est en effet
la troisième étape du déconfinement et
le ministre de la santé olive et veyran
l'a déclaré aujourd'hui l'évolution de
l'épidémie de kobe de 19 et très
favorable en conséquence le couvre-feu
pourra bien être repoussé à 23 heures
contre 21h précédemment jusqu'à 6h du
matin attention l'attestation sera
toujours demandé dans ces plages
horaires alors musées théâtres salles de
spectacles seront ouverts ainsi que les
cinémas avec des protocoles spécifiques
jusqu'au 30 juin 65 % de l'effectif mais
jusqu'à 5000 personnes par salle tout de
même mais festival de plein air pourront
également se tenir avec évidemment des
personnes à 6,1 et une jauge de 65%
autre grande nouvelle à pour les salles
de sport fermé elles pourront rouvrir
avec 50% de la jauge côté sportif et 65%
du côté des spectateurs alors il faut
savoir que de nombreux événements
pourront se tenir mais jusqu'à 5000
personnes assises
en revanche le pass sanitaire sera
obligatoire à partir de 1000 personnes
a pass sanitaire qui entre en vigueur
aujourd'hui mais qui ne sera pas
obligatoire pour les restaurants les
théâtres et les cinémas autre grande
nouvelle bien sûr la rouverture tant
attendu des bars et des restaurants en
intérieur avec une jauge de 50% et pas
plus de six personnes par table et 4 et
un soulagement évidemment pour tous les
français mais il n'ya pas que de la joie
dans l'air tout de même 1 ne nous
emballons pas trop
[Musique]
et bien non toujours un petit parfum de
polémique car la campagne de vaccination
continue à vive allure mais elle fait
quand même grincer des dents encore
aujourd'hui début juin emmanuel macron a
annoncé que les 12 15 ans serait
exigible à la vaccination à partir du 15
juin
mais cela n'a pas plu au conseil
consultatif national d'éthique présidée
par jean françois delfraissy
il a réagi une semaine plus tard le
comité estime que son avis aurait dû
être consulté avant de prendre une telle
décision
et selon lui le bénéfice médical
individuel que les adolescents
pourraient en retirer reste très limité
second argument je cite le recul
existants ne permet pas d'assurer la
pleine sécurité de ces nouveaux vaccins
chez l'adolescent alors un conseil du
comité et bien que les parents ne soient
pas les seuls décisionnaires
il faudrait selon lui recueillir le
consentement éclairé des adolescents
candidats au vaccin
merci katia technique et nouveauté un de
cette troisième étape du déconfinement
le passé ni terre pour accéder à
certains lieux et événements de plus de
1000 personnes présentées sous la forme
d'un qr code sur papier ou via l'appli
tous antico vide dans kelly le sera-t-il
obligatoire comment l'obtenir
éléments de réponse avec monaco dès lors
les beaux jours arrivent ça sent l'été
et chacun espère un retour à une vie
normale mais avant cela il faudra
prendre quelques précautions
à compter de ce mercredi 9 juin le
gouvernement passe à la troisième étape
de son plan déconfinement avec la mise
en place du pass sanitaire le graal pour
accéder au rassemblement de plus de 1000
personnes à savoir et les concerts les
salons et les foires mais aussi les
matchs dans les stades les casinos ou
encore lé festival le transport aérien
et les croisières seront également
concernés mais attention beaucoup de
faits qu'il nie aussi recul à ce sujet
ce n'est pas un passeport vaccinale pour
plutôt le voir comme une sorte de
pochettes dans laquelle vous pourrez
glisser l'un de ces trois documents un
certificat de tests pcr un certificat de
vaccination ou encore un certificat de
rétablissement pour ceux qui ont déjà
attrapé le coc vide
ces certificats présente
des qr codes et pourront être stockés
dans l'application tous sentis co-lead
développé par le gouvernement et si vous
n'avez pas de smartphone pas de panique
vous pourrez également présenter ces
documents sous forme papier se passe
sanitaire ne sera pas nécessaire pour
les moins de 11 ans et surtout pas
d'obligation d'avoir un pass sanitaires
pour accéder au lieu de la vie
quotidienne comme les restaurants les
cinémas les musées les parcs
d'attraction ou encore les grands
magasins le pass sanitaire ne sera
jamais un droit d'accès qui différencie
les français il ne saurait être
obligatoire pour accéder au lieu de la
vie de tous les jours comme les
restaurants théâtres et cinémas ou pour
aller chez des amis par contre dans des
lieux où se brassent les foules comme
les stades festivals foires ou
expositions il serait absurde de ne pas
l'utiliser
ce sera un outil supplémentaire pour
assurer la protection des français
le secrétaire d'état cdh rico lui
confirme que si un de ces établissements
impose la présentation du pass à son
entrée vous pourrez porter plainte et
mais du côté de l'opposition le pass
sanitaire fait grincer des dents
je m'inquiète de voir la société dans
laquelle on est en train de basculer
je m'inquiète de cette idée que
systématiquement pour avoir accès à des
loisirs où on serait nombreuses nombreux
il faudrait absolument recourir un
document le pass sanitaire va être
réservé aux loisirs mais pour aller
bosser
y compris dans des situations des
travailleuses et travailleurs prennent
des risques
on ne vous demandera pas le pass
sanitaires cette situation pourrait être
appelé à se renouveler avec d'autres
pandémies tirer le fil du passeport
sanitaire vous tomberez sur une société
de ségrégation selon l'état de santé et
sur l'eugénisme
tous les verrous sautron on met le doigt
dans un engrenage monstrueux 0 débat
éthique ni morale valider ça c'est
porter une immense responsabilité de son
côté la cnil gendarmes de la protection
des données personnelles dit être
favorable à ce passe sanitaire mais
demandent des garanties pour prévenir l
les dérives la cnil souligne que le
dispositif devra intégrer un certain
nombre de garanties afin de limiter
autant que possible la divulgation et la
conservation d'informations privées et
d'éviter tout risque de discrimination
en raison de l'état de santé
mais également en raison de la capacité
d'accès et d' usage des outils
numériques
en attendant le gouvernement tente de
rassurer comme il peut les plus
sceptiques
il ne s'agit pas de fliquer les gens de
montrer un pedigree de montrer dans la
durée et qu'on est protégée contre le
virus mais de permettre de rouvrir des
événements qui sinon ne pourraient pas
se tenir dès le 26 juin c'est le pass
sanitaire européen qui devrait être mis
en place il sera commun aux 27 états
membres de l'union européenne
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
alexis poulain éditorialistes bonsoir
alexis merci d'être avec nous ce soir
avant de répondre à nos questions je
voudrais juste vous faire écouter
gabriel atta le porte parole du
gouvernement qui s'est exprimée
justement sur ce pass sanitaire
aujourd'hui à l'issue du conseil des
ministres
aujourd'hui une nouvelle se met en place
le pass sanitaires le pass sanitaire
c'est la liberté c'est la capacité à
aller dans de grands rassemblements
sportifs ou culturels avec un certificat
de vaccination ou avec un résultat de
test négatif
c'est ce qui permet à toute la vie de
reprendre c'est ce qui permet de
profiter à nouveau de la culture et du
sport dans leur plénitude
alors le pas sanitaire c'est la liberté
en europe mouvants de gabriella talent
mais pas forcément de la vni tôt les
cheveux au vent je vais y arriver
pas forcément l'avis de tous le monde
alexis oui alors
moi ça me fait froid dans le dos en fait
quand j'entends ce genre de phrase veut
pas sanitaire c'est la liberté j'ai
l'impression d'être dans 1984 le livre
de orwell et d'avoir le mini vers le
ministère de la vérité
la guerre c'est la paix et cette
application de contrôle des populations
et des déplacements liés à l'état de
santé des uns et des autres serait le
pass vers la liberté alors qu'il est un
instrument de contrôle des uns et des
autres comment peut-on croire une
seconde que ce document mal fait sans
doute grandement inutile on voit que
certains pays qui ont massivement
vaccinés ont laissé tomber cette idée de
passes sanitaires beaucoup de pays ne
l'ont pas la floride a refusé d'avoir ce
type de document d'autres états
américains ont suivi et voilà que
l'europe s'empresse à avoir ce document
qui permet d'une certaine façon de faire
tomber schengen sans le dire c'est à
dire que ça permettait européen de
remettre des frontières cette fois-ci
biotechnologique biologique en fonction
de l'état de santé des uns et des autres
ça permet aussi de casser l'égalité des
citoyens alors on nous dit que c'est
pour protéger tout le monde
non il s'agit de contrôler tout le monde
et ses données d'ailleurs ne sont pas
sécurisées on apprend ce soir que les
documents qui transite un de ce pass and
i ter vers les organismes de contrôle
passe par
des systèmes américains l'entreprise
akamai qui va avoir accès à ses données
de manière tout à fait transparente et
qui va pouvoir faire une moisson de
données sur l'état de santé des français
donc encore une fois aucune pensée sur
la souveraineté ce que ça peut être la
quadrature du net va déposer des recours
la cnil se pose des questions et les
français bien ils se disent bon on va
être obligé si on veut retourner dans
des festivals retrouver une vie entre
guillemets normal puisqu'il faudra
respecter les gestes barrière mettre le
masque parfois faire des tests pcr donc
se passe sanitaires il n'est
certainement pas la liberté
il est l'assurance de rentrer dans autre
chose que la démocratie libérale
on est en train tout simplement de
mettre en place un système de contrôle
citoyen d'ailleurs un rapport du sénat
vient d'être remis par des rapporteurs
du sénat qui disent que dans le futur
grâce à ces données numériques sur la
santé des français ou sur leurs
déplacements
on pourra retirer le droit de
déplacement ou bien bloquer les comptes
en banque de personnes qui ne
respecteraient pas la quarantaine qui ne
serait pas dans les clous en fonction
des lois scélérates qui seront pendus
compte tenu de l'état d'urgence
permanent dans lequel nous vivons
donc non ce pass sanitaire de grâce
qu'on nous vante pas comme un élément de
la liberté retrouvée
il est simplement un élément d'un
service man supplémentaire de
populations qu'ils sont usés
rincés par déjà un an quasiment de
couvre-feu de mesures restrictives tout
ça soit disant pour leur santé oui
effectivement vous vous l'avez mentionné
un la cnil qui a rendu un avis sur ce
passé et qui note beaucoup de deux
pistes d'amélioration l ex ipass
sanitaire obligatoire pour des
événements de plus de 1000 personnes on
l'a dit mais pas que par exemple si vous
voulez les encore c'est bien il est
indispensable sauf à faire un petit pc
air très agréable à l'aller et au retour
mais on ne peut pas voyager sans se
passe donc peut-être pas obligatoire
mais un peu quand même mais complètement
il fait partie de ces de cette boîte à
outils un du nudge 7 ou sociologie
comportementale qui permet d'obliger les
foules à faire des choses qu'elles
refusent ou qu'elles sont reluctant
tafer en l'occurrence se faire vacciner
l'idée c'est de dire eh bien pour être
tranquille ça y est je vais faire ma
piqûre et je rêvais pas sanitaires et on
embête rappaz je pourrais faire ce que
je veux donc c'est un outil qui permet
simplement de pousser les gens à ça mais
je le disais ce pas sanitaire
n'empêchera pas dedans le belmas qu'il
n'empêchera pas le respect des
gestes-barrières il n'empêchera pas
parfois les tests pcr et puis quel
imbroglio juridique à venir que faire
des pays qui n'ont pas on va accepter
alors les touristes américains qui
viennent vacciner sans passani terme et
on va dire à certains parce que vous
avez le vaccin skotnik par exemple ça ne
rentrent pas dans les clous alors
comment on va faire au niveau
international et puis au niveau national
on voit bien les dérives qui vont sans
doute s'immiscer entre les gens qui ont
compris ceux qui n'ont pas compris
alors on commence à dire se passe n'est
pas nécessaire pour aller au cinéma au
restaurant etc
mais qu'en sera-t-il en septembre en
octobre que se passe-t-il si une
nouvelle vague arrive et que ce pas
sanitaire est mis en place
là on verra on rentrera dans le dur de
ce système de contrôle des populations
de data de big data l'idée c'est d'avoir
des données sur tout tout le monde et
tout le temps le problème c'est que ces
données et la cnil demande des garanties
elle a raison parce qu'aujourd'hui ne
sont pas sécurisées et elle passe par
des organismes tiers
une entreprise américaine je le disais
akamai mais d'autres il n'y a aucune
garantie sur la sécurisation de ces
données la privatisation de ces données
on est en train de d'ouvrir un grand
livre en fête sur la santé de tous les
français pour permettre encore une fois
aux gars femmes et aux autres biens
de faire ci qui savent le faire le mieux
des moissons de données personnelles or
aujourd'hui la données personnelles
c'est une arme de guerre c'est vraiment
la façon de faire un maximum de profits
on voit le monstre facebook tel qu'il
est devenu cette plateforme
et voilà que se passe à lithaire entre
encore comme si ça devait devenir
quelque chose du quotidien non c'est
quelque chose d'exceptionnel
et c'est quelque chose de dangereux
parce qu'on va rentrer dans une
citoyenneté à la carte parce qu'on va
briser l'égalité et parce que cela n'a
rien à voir encore une fois avec l'état
de santé des populations
merci avec six poulains d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france et
concernant présent les voyages à
l'étranger bruxelles donne son feu vert
aux certificats numériques qu'ovide
européen les eurodéputés ont largement
adopté le dispositif hier c'est
certificat qui atteste de la vaccination
d'une personne d'un test négatif ou
d'une immunité après une injection
délivrer gratuitement ils doivent
permettre d'éviter des quarantaines dans
les pays de destination
autre objectif faciliter le
rétablissement de la libre circulation
entre états membres
nous avons celui les acteurs qui étaient
en route ont été enregistrés notamment
avec le parlement européen sur le sujet
nous allons continuer à travailler à
faire en sorte que l'on puisse
progressivement restaurés la libre
circulation des personnes avec une
attention particulière pour les impacts
économiques qui sont liées notamment
dans certains pays ils sont directement
concernés par le secteur touristique
optimisme prudent
c'est évidemment le sentiment largement
partagé autour de la table
l'état condamné pour faute lourde pour
des faits de contrôle au faciès la cour
d'appel de paris a rendu son verdict
mardi dans une affaire de contrôle de
police sur trois lycéens
les faits remontent à plusieurs années
un arrêt qui met en lumière la
problématique des contrôles au faciès en
france gaymard aussi nous sommes gare du
nord à paris le 1er mars 2017 vers 20
heures une vingtaine d'élèves reviennent
d'un court séjour pédagogique à
bruxelles en descendant du thalys trois
d'entre eux sont appréhendés par les
forces de l'ordre pour un contrôle
d'identité
au menu palpation tutoiement est fou il
dévalise sous le regard des passants
ces trois élèves se sont mamadou camara
il y à sada j ai accarias hadji madi et
suite à ce contrôle qui les ont jugé
humiliant et discriminatoire il décide
de porter plainte contre l'état
déboutée en première instance en 2018
ils ont obtenu gain de cause ce mardi
devant la cour d'appel de la capitale
les caractéristiques physiques des
personnes contrôlées notamment leur
origine leur âge et leur sexe ont été la
cause réelle du contrôle et met en
évidence une différence de traitement
laissant présumer l'existence d'une
discrimination
le contrôle d'identité est jugée
discriminatoire et constitue une faute
lourde de l'état
verdict l'état est condamné à verser
1500 euros en réparation du préjudice
moral subi
à chacune des trois victimes de ce
contrôle au faciès alors si cette
affaire est intéressante c'est notamment
parce que pour caractériser l'aspect
discriminatoire du contrôle la haute
juridiction âge site jauger
l'échantillon contrôlé non pas par
rapport à l'effectif de la classe
entière composée exclusivement d'élèves
issus de minorités visibles mais par
rapport à l'ensemble de la population
qui descendant du train se trouvait sur
le quai et n'a pas été contrôlé ce
faisant la cour constate ce que
plusieurs études ont déjà démontré à
savoir une sur représentation des
personnes issues de minorités visibles
parmi les individus concernés par les
contrôles de police
en 2012 une étude publiée dans la revue
scientifique population c'est justement
intéressé aux contrôles réalisés en gare
du nord y compris et cela tombe bien au
niveau des thalys et le constat est
édifiant
les personnes blanches ils représentent
86% des voyageurs mais seulement la
moitié des personnes contrôlées tandis
que les personnes noires représente
7 % de celles et ceux qui transitent
pour 23% de ses contrôles à âge sexe et
encombrement égal c'est à dire si la
personne a un bagage ou non une personne
noire à près de cinq fois plus de
chances d'être contrôlé qu'un blanc au
niveau des catalyst de la gare du nord
et la tendance est similaire au niveau
national un rapport du défenseur des
droits publié en 2017 concluait qu'a
lieu de résidence niveau de diplôme et
situation financière égale les jeunes
sommes perçues comme arabes ou noirs
avaient une probabilité 20 fois plus
élevé que les autres de subir un
contrôle des forces de l'ordre et pour
en parler nous sommes avec il y as l'un
des trois un lycéen victimes de ce
contrôle discriminatoire en 2017 bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france vous a faite par votre prénom
parce que vous ne souhaitez pas qu'on
dévoile votre nom et c'est bien votre
droit quelle est votre réaction après ce
verdict est ce que vous vous sentez
soulagé bah franchement je me sens que
je me sens soulagé je suis content
franchement j'aurais jamais cru qu'on
aurait pu gagner contre l'état j'espère
que ça va faire ça va faire évoluer les
choses je tiens à remercier madame élise
baucherel mon professeur parce que grâce
à elle et monsieur slim ben achour ce
combat était très difficile je n'aurais
jamais cru hélas aujourd'hui je suis
content je tous mes amis m'en parler
franchement je suis super heureux pour
vous clairement justice a été faite
ouais franchement pas là était fait mais
j'espère j'espère qu'on verra avec le
temps qu'on verra que quelque chose
c'est parce que ça a évolué quoi vous
vous pensé justement pas j'imagine que
c'est votre souhait que cette affaire
comme on dit en droit fassent
jurisprudence face daté et sert
peut-être relate d'exemple pour pour
l'avenir vous vous y croyez à ça
franchement moi j'y crois parce que le
combat qu'on a mené vous savez gagner
contre l'état c'est pas tout le monde
qui le fait on a gagné contre
au début j'y croyais pas le combat était
très difficile et maintenant j'espère
que que les choses évoluent quoi et que
franchement j'y prends un peu c'est
vraiment c'est un premier pas c'est un
premier pas et j'espère qu'avec le temps
ça changera on n'était évidemment pas au
procès alors on aimerait savoir s
des mots qui vous ont vraiment apaisé il
ya eu des mots forts peut-être de la
part du juge
quand il ya eu ce jugement des mots qui
vous ont fait du bien et qu'il faut
retenir avec vous pouvez nous parler
franchement aux jugements au jugement
c'était c'est l'avocat qui a parlé le
l'avocat il a beaucoup m'a beaucoup
touché sur pas mal de mots sur caisse
parce qu'il a beaucoup essayé de nous
défendre et quand j'ai vu que l' affaire
a été renvoyée à la course à la cour
d'appel et que après et caplong moi j'y
croyais plus personnellement j'y croyais
plus je me suis dit c'est pas possible
même mes amis des amis à moins d'une
sévère franchement ça il ya énormément
de monde il ya beaucoup d'arabes et de
noirs et de français de beaucoup de
personnes blanches et tout est
franchement je me suis peut-être que je
ne crois pas à chaque fois on renvoie
les choses
les juges ont été faire et on a notre
avocat nous a montré que fallait croire
il fallait aller jusqu'au bout et
aujourd'hui regardez c'est un premier
pas dans l'avenir
depuis cette affaire qui date de 2017
est ce que vous avez subi d'autres
contrôles que vous avez jugé
discriminatoire est ce que c'est le
quotidien des minorités selon vous
réellement vous vous constatez au
quotidien peut-être même avec des amis à
vous bah franchement madame tâche pas
contrôles discriminatoires non parce que
là le contrôle je me suis fait contrôler
c'est était dans le train je prends plus
trop souvent le train parce que j'ai une
voiture maintenant et et ouais je me
suis contrôlé deux trois fois mais un
peu moins quoi avant c'était souvent
souvent et maintenant ça c'est un petit
peu allégés quoi vous vous sentez
peut-être qu'il ya un changement des
mentalités rousse a rien à voir
forcément non non franchement je trouve
qu'il ya en avoir non même pas non
après j'espère qu'avec le temps ils ont
deux mentalités oui ma dernière question
on parle beaucoup des caméras piétons 1
ces derniers temps est ce que vous
pouvez vous penser que ça peut permettre
justement de réduire
le nombre de contrôles au faciès a peut
être rassurant selon vous vous êtes
plutôt pour ses caméras prix des piétons
des caméras dans la rue les caméras au
qu'on donne aux policiers lors des
interpellations ça vous rassurerai vont
justement où les contrôles au faciès
pour les contrôler en général on les
contrôle
on ne sait pas et pas franchement je
vois pas quel hockey en quoi l'intérêt
de mettre des caméras mais je sais pas
quoi peut-être peut-être que je sais pas
franchement je justice a été rendue où
c'est peut-être une question un peu trop
technique je m'en excuse
justice a été rendue en tout cas pour
vous merci les assassins vous êtes
ancien donc lycéens de leur team des
contrôles discriminatoires en 2017 merci
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france on est resté avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons de joe
biden qui vient d'arriver au royaume-uni
première étape de sa tournée européenne
avec en point d'orgue la rencontre avec
vladimir poutine mercredi prochain à
genève
le président américain qui veut faire
savoir je cite clairement à poutine et à
la chine que les états unis et l'europe
sont soudés
généreux
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
le théâtre du châtelet c'est par théâtre
comme les autres c'est un théâtre qui
est très diversifiée dans un
programmation de la culture est une
activité absolument essentiel de notre
société de sa cohésion de sa cohérence
c'est aussi le rôle du châtelet de
pouvoir mettre en contact des très
belles productions avec le public
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans un théâtre en
plein confinement on a essayé de
réinventer notre métier et en
particulier on a fait beaucoup de
travail avec la télévision on a permis
de capter un certain nombre de
spectacles pour la télévision ce qui est
une autre manière de pouvoir créer la
relation avec le public et je suis sûr
qu'il y aura une grande volonté du
public de revenir dans les théâtres
[Musique]
la repentance est un sentiment aux
conséquences extrêmement graves pour
l'avenir
cette pratique obsessionnel s'impose
dans l'esprit de nos dirigeants comme la
condition incontournable d'une
gouvernance responsable moderne plutôt
que de se repentir
on ferait mieux de faire référence à un
passé dont on peut être fier
nous trouvons un autre exemple des
limites de cette transparence dans
l'utilisation de la raison d'état pour
cacher la vérité sous la pression
médiatique et la raison d'état aux
pratiques une sélection du bien et du
mal à géométrie variable
il faut sauver la liberté d'expression
qui est prise en otage dans une
inversion entre le juste et le client
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes
j'ai vraiment plongé dans une atmosphère
où j'ai vécu auprès de nero et gagarine
était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station mir ou la
station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux ans et demi plus tard vous imposer
comme un espoir français du tennis
fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris y sommes
le sport m'a toujours sauver le tennis
c'est que c'est mon sport bon il ya un
fauteuil mais je vais essayer en fait je
me suis rendu compte que c'est ça allait
c'était suffisamment physique pour moi
j'ai une vie de sportif de haut niveau
je m'entraîne tous les jours c'est
devenu ma vie la raison de me lever le
matin j'avais toujours ce vieux rêve de
petite fille de faire du sport de ma vie
est finalement là c'est c'est ce que je
réalise avec une jambe ont mangé un
autre combat non ma vie qui est celui de
la sécurité routière s'agit d'un projet
de loi qui vise à mettre en place des
tests d'aptitude pour tous les
conducteurs pas seulement les seniors on
a un contrôle technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit re doit
imposer loi sur ce sujet là
bitcoin des cardinaux tous des crypto
actifs mais ces dernières semaines trou
de 4 le cours du bitcoin s'effondre elle
perd 30% de sa valeur en quelques jours
on peut difficilement pour l'instant
parler de crash vous avez quelque chose
est monté jusqu'à 60 mille euros et qui
est redescendu à 30 mais ça vaut encore
30 millions au plus un marché est petit
plus évidemment il est il est sujet à de
la volatilité
c'est la vie d'un actif comme comme
bitcoin que de subir ce genre de crash
on essaie de vendre ça comme quelque
chose de tout à fait tranquille et qui
ne peut que monter non ça 200 bourses
aux mais comme tout je rappelle que dans
le monde il ya presque un milliard de
personnes qui ont vu en 2020 leurs
monnaies nationales se déprécier de plus
de 20%
effectivement que c'est une ça peut être
une monnaie d'échangé pour ces gens là
donc la monnaie est ce qu'elle fait en
l'occurrence si les gens s'en servent
comme une monnaie il faudra l'accepter
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième émission tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi 9 juin se voit clairement à
poutine et à la chine que les états unis
et l'europe sont soudés c'est en ces
termes que joe biden a défini le but de
son voyage en europe premier déplacement
officiel du président américain depuis
son arrivée à la maison blanche
point de départ de sa tournée le royaume
uni où il vient d'arriver à l'occasion
du g7 qui le conduira jusqu'à genève où
il doit rencontrer le président russe
que semaine prochaine
[Musique]
contexte sur le grill de la cour des
comptes européenne compétences et le
manque de transparence de lagence de
gardes frontières sont pointés du doigt
dans un audit
fondée en 2004 est chargé de veiller sur
les frontières extérieures de l'union
l'agencé une tâche immense tout comme un
budget colossal l'explosion de la rue de
trévise un drame qui a touché le 9e
arrondissement de paris en janvier 2019
une réunion est organisée au ministère
de la justice demain concernant les
indemnisations si la ville de paris et
les assureurs sont conviés à la
chancellerie n'en est rien des victimes
dont le dossier patine toujours
[Musique]
près de cinq mois après son arrivée au
pouvoir le président américain joe biden
vient tout juste d'atterrir au
royaume-uni première étape d'une tournée
européenne avec de nombreuses rencontres
bilatérales qui s'achèvera par un sommet
avec vladimir poutine
pour plus de précisions nous retrouvons
à notre reporter thomas bonnin en direct
de washington ou soir thomas jordan qui
seront donc en europe pour son premier
voyage officiel en tant que président
des états unis à quoi doit-on s'attendre
et bien c'est évidemment tout sauf un
hasard si au bayonne a choisi de se
rendre en europe pour son premier
déplacement officiel c'est un message
adressé aux alliés européens pour tenter
de renouer des relations qui ont été
quelque peu abîmée par les quatre ans de
mandat de donald trump jo bayonne veut
créer de nouvelles relations de
conscience mais il ya des points de
désaccord tout de même encore entre les
pays membres de l'union européenne et
les etats unis d'abord il ya la chine
puisque joe biden souhaiterait que les
pays européens s'aligne sur la position
américaine à savoir une position
offensive voire presque agressive avec
pékin mais ce n'est pas la volonté de
tous les pays membres puisqu'il ya par
exemple l'allemagne qui a des liens
commerciaux très fort avec la chine et
qui ne souhaitent pas forcément
s'aligner sur ce positionnement
on verra donc quelle sera la teneur des
échanges de joe biden en ce sens il ya
aussi d'autres points de désaccord il
s'agit notamment des vaccins parce que
beaucoup de pays en europe
reprocher à joe biden et aux états unis
plus largement de tarder à ouvrir la
production de vaccins aux pays les plus
pauvres et on a appris il ya quelques
instants que finalement les états unis
allaient acheter 500 millions de doses
de pfizer pour les distribuer aux pays
les plus pauvres on peut y voir là
clairement un message adressé aux pays
européens avant les rencontres qui vont
avoir lieu ces prochains jours autres
points également qui devrait être
éclaircis celui de la réciprocité de
l'ouverture des voyages pour les
ressortissants européens en direction
des états unis en tout cas joe biden l'a
dit il l'a répété il veut renouer de
bonnes relations avec les pays européens
est évidemment lorsqu'il va rencontrer
les différents représentants et va
tenter de fédérer les
allier donc comme il les appelle autour
des menaces en tout cas ce qu'il
considère comme être des menaces à
savoir donc la chine on a parlé mais
aussi la russie est thomas parmi les
déplacements les plus attendus il ya
évidemment celui à genève pour y
rencontrer vladimir poutine oui et c'est
pas un hasard si le journaliste qui lui
a posé une question juste avant son
départ tout à l'heure depuis washington
l'a interrogé justement sur la teneur
des discussions qu'il compte à voir avec
le président russe vladimir poutine
c'est la rencontre la plus attendue et
qui sera sans doute la plus suivie si
aux états unis même si certains dans les
colonnes de certains médias américains
se demandent si c'est pertinent
finalement de rencontrer le président
russe s'est évidemment ces critiques ne
viennent pas des plus russophiles des
américains mais elle arrive notamment de
la part de l'ambassadeur américain en
russie qui à la veille de l'annoncé de
la rencontre entre joe biden et vladimir
poutine avait tenu des propos en privé
qu'ils ont été rapportés par le média
cnn il disait redouter que la nouvelle
administration de se montre trop
conciliante avec moscou et s'est
finalement pas le seul officiel à tenir
ce genre de discours alors il ya eu une
réponse du secrétaire général de l'otan
en début de semaine qui a été reçu à la
maison blanche
je propose de l'écouter le dialogue avec
la russie n'est pas un signe de
faiblesse nous sommes forts nous sommes
unis nous pourrons parler à la russie et
nous devons lui parler il nous faut
avoir une meilleure relation même si
nous doutons de cela nous avons besoin
de gérer cette relation difficile avec
la russie le contrôle des armes la
transparence la réduction des risques
toutes ces questions sont importantes
alors la maison blanche défend aussi
cette rencontre en expliquant que c'est
important pour joe biden de pouvoir
rencontrer en personne les différents
interlocuteurs on sait qu'il aimait
beaucoup lorsqu'il était vice-président
de barack obama se déplace et justement
lors de ces sommets bilatéraux on verra
maintenant ce qu'il en est puisqu'il est
désormais président des états unis il
est donc décideurs et ça change
évidemment pas mal de choses en tout cas
en ce qui concerne la rencontre entre
joe biden et vladimir poutine on n'est
pas vraiment sûr d'avoir des annonces
concrètes
on n'est pas sûr non plus qu'il y ait
une conférence de presse conjointe à
l'issue
question merci thomas bonnin en direct
de washington et le mois point final du
voyage de jubail en europe en europe
sera donc on vient d'en parler nommant
face à face avec vladimir poutine ce
sera le 16 juin à genève sergueï lavrov
le chef de la diplomatie russe a tenu
une conférence de presse est ce sujet
ont fait le point avec notre
correspondante à moscou vera goffman la
russie n'a pas d'ambition de
superpuissance a déclaré le chef de la
diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov la
russie est intéressée par des relations
pragmatiques mutuellement avantageuse
avec tout le monde que ce soit les états
unis ou l'union européenne ni les
sanctions ni les ultimatums ne
conviennent pour dialoguer avec la
russie jo propose d'écouter
nous sommes constamment intéressés par
des relations pragmatiques mutuellement
avantageuse avec tous notamment
l'occident lui même que ce soit les
états unis leurs alliés au sein de
l'otan ou l'union européenne il n'y aura
pas de jeu à sens unique ni les
sanctions ni les ultimatums ne
conviennent pour dialoguer avec nous
nous n'avons pas d'ambition de super
puissance même si certains se
convainquent et convainque tous les
autres du contraire nous n'avons pas non
plus l'ardeur messianique avec laquelle
nos collègues occidentaux s'efforce de
répondre leur ordre du jour en fondée
sur des valeurs démocratiques partout à
travers le globe
nous comprenons depuis longtemps que
l'imposition des modèles de
développement de l'extérieur n'aboutit à
rien de bon je tiens à souligner une
fois encore que nous nous prononçons
pour la coopération avec tous sur la
base du respect mutuel de l'égalité de
droit et de la recherche d'un équilibre
entre les intérêts nous voyons la valeur
individuelle dans chaque partenaire
international dans le cadre des
relations bilatérales
aussi bien que dans des domaines
internationaux je chéris sont l'amitié
avec tous ceux qui nous répondent par la
réciprocité et sont prêts à rechercher
des accords honnête au lieu d'essayer
d'utiliser des ultimatums et des
exigences unilatérale à l'onu
sergey lavrov a également évoqué l'état
des relations russo américaines en
du sommet poutine byden qui se tiendra
le 16 juin à genève
le travail continue
il ne reste pas longtemps à attendre je
pense que bientôt tout sera clair sommes
intéressés à l'idée de résultats
positifs au sommet mais comme on dit il
faut être deux pour danser le tango
et si quelqu'un danse le breakdance ce
sera probablement plus difficile
le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères a également souligné que
malgré les divergences qui existent
entre les deux pays qui paraissent pour
certains insurmontable il est important
de dialoguer au plus haut niveau
et parmi les sujets épineux de cette
tournée européenne la construction du
gazoduc nord stream 2 qui continue
d'inquiéter l'europe et des états unis
d'abord opposé à son aboutissement le
président américain joe biden a
finalement renoncé à appliquer des
sanctions contre les acteurs principaux
du projet et en chine tonnes et berlin
ont annoncé aujourd'hui vouloir coopérer
afin de sauvegarder les droits de
transit ukrainien menacé par une mise en
place du gazoduc
florian lambert washington et berlin se
disent prêts à compliquer la mise en
service du gazoduc nord stream 2 après
avoir décidé fin mai de ne pas
sanctionner les protagonistes du projet
notamment le géant gazier russe gazprom
le gouvernement de dubaï dun assure
coopérer avec l'allemagne afin de
limiter les éventuels effets négatifs du
gazoduc
une fois construit critiqué par de
nombreux élus américains notamment de
son propre camp démocrate
le secrétaire d'état américain anthony
blinken justifie cette décision
selon lui le projet du gazoduc était
trop avancé lors de l'arrivée de joe
biden à la maison blanche pour pouvoir
s'y opposer le pire résultat possible de
notre point de vue pourrais tu étais une
construction du gazoduc terminé la
relation avec l'allemagne empoisonné et
aucune incitation pour l'allemagne à
travailler avec nous mais les gones pour
atténuer les graves conséquences
négatives de ce projet les allemands
discute maintenant avec nous nous
dialoguons activement avec
le tracé de nord stream ii qui relie
directement la russie à l'allemagne à
travers la mer baltique menace les
droits de transit sur le gaz russe à
destination de l'union européenne
toucher jusqu'à lors par l'ukraine
selon sergueï lavrov ministre russe des
affaires étrangères
moscou se dit prêt à discuter avec
l'ukraine et en vite l'union européenne
à prendre ses responsabilités vis-à-vis
de son partenaire ukrainien
l'histoire concernant le nord stream ii
n'est pas terminée vichot chez le muc
même plus
j'ai vu les nouveaux commentaires de
monsieur blinken selon lesquelles les
états unis étudier des moyens de
maintenir les droits de transit
ukrainien pour les livraisons de gaz
vers l'union européenne nous avons un
accord de transit avec l'ukraine pour la
période allant jusqu'à l'année 2024
il reste à discuter de la suite mais dès
maintenant l'administration américaine
souhaite éviter que l'ukraine ne souffre
du muscle oblique
selon monsieur blinken une des solutions
est de prolonger l'accord de transit
pour de nombreuses années à venir pour
que l'ukraine touche des droits de
transit pour une autre solution si la
première ne marche pas consiste à
trouver un moyen de compenser les pertes
financières à kiev
c'est ce dont les européens devront
s'occuper de nos jeunes au bout d'une
visite ce livre north stream ii sera
certainement l'un des sujets évoqués
durant le sommet entre joe biden est
vladimir poutine prévue le 16 juin
prochain genève
de son côté moscou se dit prêt à achever
la construction du gazoduc d'ici la fin
de l'année
seuls 100 km reste à construire et pour
en parler nous sommes avec eugène berg
ancien diplomate hauteur de la russie
pour les nuls aux éditions first bonsoir
gène berg merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rtl
concernant tout d'abord ce revirement de
la part de joe biden pourquoi le
président américain selon vous est il
décidé de te faire un cadeau à un gala
merkel alors qu'elle est en fin de
mandat et surtout à vladimir
poutine qu'ils traitaient il ya encore
quelques semaines de deux tu as écouté
c'était prévu déjà depuis des semaines
et des semaines
je crois que l'administration byden et
réaliste elle brandit pas des menaces
qu'elle ne pourra pas mettre en oeuvre
le le gazoduc comme l'a dit il est
terminé il reste plus qu'un mois et demi
de construction il ya moins de 100 km 94
même 50 et donc c'est une cause perdue
il a très bien dit qui aurait envenimé à
la fois les rapports étaient russes les
allemands et donc c'était un enjeu qui
n'était pas vraiment important
maintenant pour washington qui veut
maintenant on en parlera peut-être tout
à l'heure bien sûr replacer les
relations avec la russie dans un cadre
beaucoup plus globale et donc d'assurer
une stabilité stratégique et surtout une
président humilité et donc là dessus
c'est quand même un geste de bonne
volonté et en bonne diplomatie
évidemment les américains attendront un
geste de réciprocité de la part de
vanières poutine
c'est justement cet équilibre très
délicat que les observateurs les moins
bien intentionnés vont observer et que
les critiques vont si c'était qu'elle
n'est pas maintenu si on a l'impression
que c'est l'une des parties qui a
emporté un peu plus à ce moment là joba
edel sera un peu critiqué voilà un petit
peu alors évidemment on dit qui aura pas
de communiqué andy tiens ça va être
difficile
tout ça c'est des manoeuvres pré-sommet
ses classiques
je rappelle aux as nous chargent
auditeurs qu' il n'y a pas eu vraiment
de sommets depuis 2009 c'est exactement
lorsque carter avait rencontré drège des
179 ensuite reagan a rencontré caen bat
chef en 85 qui s'est passé énormément
d'année là c'est quand même le premier
sommet et qui est dans une qui se devait
se tenir dans une atmosphère difficile
certes tendu on le verra mais au moins
il ya un geste de bonne volonté des deux
côtés
s
ce cet aspect là qu'il faut mettre
l'accent
mon sens juste avant le décollage à bord
de l'avion forcé air force one le
président américain a tout de même
assuré que le but de son voyage était de
le faire savoir clairement je suis ta
putin et à la chine que les états unis
et l'europe étaient soudés on se dit ça
mais quand même pas en confiance tout ça
pour apaiser des rapports comme vous
nous le décrivions il ya quelques
instants nombre c'est normal il va pas
dire que l'europe et les états unis
puisque il vient il vient on va pas
reparler tous les sommets qui fait il
veut il veut rassembler le monde
démocratique effectivement le fameux
dédie ce coin de faire un sommet des
démocraties et donc mon la chine on n'en
parle pas parce que c'est vraiment c'est
là le point délicat le point justement
il faut il faut mettre de côté
l'affrontement entre les etats-unis et
la chine qui est un affrontement vue
technologique stratégie commerciale
civilisationnel de rapports plus
difficiles avec la russie que je que que
lui-même byden ne qualifie pas
d'affrontement puisque le vrai
affrontement ce avec la chine alors
certains américains nourrissent j'aurais
pas l'illusion l'espérance qu'un jour on
va des tâches et la russie de la chine
charge hawks et c'est pas envisagée
avant avant très longtemps donc
concrètement c'est normal puisque
poutine est un interlocuteur très
difficile coriace qui a montré son
habileté byden montre il
il montre très bien qui n'est pas un
naïf et qui vient également pour
négocier et trouver un accord trouvé un
accord pour il n'y aura pas un accord
peut-être actes et surtout les plombs
puisque c'est trop tôt pour discuter de
manière technique sur le sur le
nucléaire sur le terrorisme souvenez
vous la dernière fois on a discuté que
lavrov avait proposé une réunion des
chefs d'état major
on verra ce qu'il sortira du 16 mai au
moins
il y aura une rencontre des deux chefs
d'état qui se connaissent déjà
ils vont déblayer un saut d'obstacles et
on verra si effectivement il y aura une
différence de perception et surtout une
volonté d'approfondir ce que j'appelle
une première petite percée je l'espère
une petite percée c'est pas évidemment
c'est pas d'un seul coup on va pas
régler le contentieux qui existe déjà
depuis une dizaine d'années bien avant
l'ukraine
les rapports se sont détériorées à
propos de la série des des détresses des
12 mai au moins j'assiste là dessus il
ya une volonté des deux chefs d'états
d'établir et surtout de passer en revue
une série de questions telles que le
terrorisme le désarmement le changement
climatique l'écologie avait parlé de
l'arctique byden par là évidemment des
droits de l'homme du canada ni donc une
putin voudra parler également de
l'assaut sur le congrès de 6 en disant
oui vous le critiquez mais vous aussi
vous n'êtes pas irréprochable donc
essayons de rétablir la balance telle
qu'elle est voilà un petit peu l'optique
de ce sommet et je crois que c'est par
rapport à ces critères qu'il faudra
juger s'il a été positif succès toujours
c'est par une de boxe finalement c'est
pas quelqu'un qui assènent des coups à
l'autre souvent la presse dit voilà
c'est séverine de boeck
non le succès sera le qui aura une
progression c'est à dire que le sommet
aura été une valeur ajoutée dans la
compréhension qu'ont les deux présidents
de la situation actuelle et une un
éclaircissement des points sur lesquels
on peut progresser avec de la bonne
volonté
si les circonstances le permettent et si
chacun y met de la bonne volonté alors
souvent dans ce genre de situation
évidemment les rapports personnels jouen
pèse la porte parole de la maison
blanche a rappelé avant ceux des parents
que joe biden connaissait certains de
ses biens
jean dont le président poutine depuis
des décennies at elle dit quelle est la
relation entre ces deux hommes vous vous
la voyez comment pas pour l'instant
vous savez c'est eux on a beaucoup de
photos en tête ou deux le vice-président
en 2011 les revêt un coran j'étais en
russie à l'époque
finalement ils ont jamais eu d'atomes
crochus
il n'y a pas une vraie sympathie entre
les deux hommes comme il y en a pas eu
entre obama et poutine d'heure poutine a
des bonnes relations
par exemple il avait avec avec beaucoup
d'autres dirigeants et pas uniquement de
son équipe de son groupe de son décès ne
sont de sa catégorie mais avec baden
pour l'instant ce ça a été purement
factuel c'est ce n'a pas été vraiment
chaleureux alors est-ce que la glace vin
brisé je pense pas dès la première n'est
pas la première parce que by dell
justement veut se démarquer de 33 me
disais moi je les bons rapports je
respecte poutine
mais en même temps je suis dur il joue
un peu le double jeu quoi jouer les
matamores en disant je me fais pas
rouler alors qui c'est un petit peu
comme il a critiqué ses propres services
de sécurité maiden qui est un vrai
professionnel ne fera pas donc
effectivement pour l'instant les
relations sans être froide sont
distantes sont des relations de travail
et pour bâtir ses relations vous avez
tout à fait raison
il faudra d'autres sommets alors est ce
que là la pratique annuelle des sommets
que j'ai connus lorsque j'ai commencé ma
carrière l'étudiant où tous les ans ils
se voyaient ils se voyaient en 72 73 sur
le 14 sera ce serait effectivement
intéressant puisque ça montrerait que il
ya un début de redémarrage
y'a pas évidemment de détente c'est
beaucoup trop tôt d'en parler mais il ya
une volonté comme je dirais de déblayer
ces problèmes de les examiner ensuite
demandé aux ministres et aux techniciens
de se pencher est d'arriver à des à des
modus vivendi ou dédé semblant d'accord
donc ça serait bien mais
qu'effectivement les deux hommes
établissent des relations travailler
justement le sait jouer c'est l'occasion
de tester cette possibilité de continuer
à travailler ensemble et se réunir en
tête à tête pratiquement une fois par an
merci aux jeunes à bergues d'avoir été
avec nous nous avons apporté notre
analyse en direct sur rt france le
suspense reste entier au pérou le
candidat socialiste pedro castillo a
élargi son avance contre sa rivale
populiste keiko fujimori
les résultats définitifs de la
présidentielle sont attendus dans
quelques heures les votes d'un millions
de péruviens les aidant à l'étranger
pour être encore inverser la tendance
pierre yana trois jours que le pérou et
dans la tente d'un nouveau président
c'est le statu quo dans le pays alors
que pedro castillo et keiko fujimori
sont toujours au coude à coude et que
99% des bulletins ont été dépouillés
face à l'incertitude la colère du peuple
en fleurs à lima des centaines de
partisans des deux camps ont rallié les
bureaux de la commission nationale
électorale pour dénoncer des soupçons de
fraude
nous exigeons qu'ils déclarent déjà
castillo président l'homme a gagné dans
19 provinces et la dame n'a gagné que
dans six ou sept seulement il est
évident qu'il mijote de la fraude
je suis ici pour défendre les votes de
tous les péruviens de villa el salvador
j'étais coordinatrice de neuf tables de
vote et dans ses neuf tables keiko a
gagné et la même chose pour toutes la
villa el salvador et je suis ici pour
défendre les voix de tous mes voisins un
peuple divisé par une polémique qui a
pris de l'ampleur lorsque la candidate
de la droite populiste a fait état d'
indices de fraude et d'irrégularités
dans le scrutin des soupçons balayé par
son rival de la gauche radicale qui a
lancé un appel au calme
je suis ici devant vous sans aucun
intérêt personnel sans aucun intérêts
mesquins
je suis ici pour le pérou camarades
compatriote frères et soeurs restés
calmes
nous ne nous lasserons pas de dire ce
que nous avons toujours dit seul le
peuple sauvera le peuple
quoi qu'il en soit le futur vainqueur
prendra les rênes d'un pays ravagé par
la corruption
une corruption dont les six derniers
présidents font ou ont fait l'objet
d'une enquête
à cela s'ajoute la crise sanitaire 184
mille personnes sont mortes du
coronavirus ce qui fait du pérou le pays
le plus endeuillé au monde en termes de
proportion de sa population
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur l'audit sévère de
la cour des comptes concernant l' agence
de protection des frontières européennes
incompétence et manque de transparence
sont notamment pointés du doigt et puis
nous parlerons de l'explosion de la rue
de trévise plus de deux ans après le
drame les victimes n'ont toujours pas
été indemnisés
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle les gens qui
font appel à moi s'engage dans un combat
c'est parce que il ya de l'autre côté
une classe ultra privilégiés qui est
prête à sacrifier l'être humain en
réalité pour accroître encore davantage
ses richesses
les chiffres qui sont avancés qui sont
montrés aux salariés et à leurs
représentants sont des chiffres en
décalage parfois vertigineux avec les
chiffres que l'on trouve dans la
comptabilité officielle notre travail
c'est justement de 10,6 pc et écrans de
fumée de gratter le maquillage et de
faire émerger la réalité des profits
gigantesques que réalise et fiable mais
comment peuvent-ils mentir comme des
arracheurs de dents ce point
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bitcoin de cardin autour des crypto
actifs mais ces dernières semaines pour
2 4 le cours du bitcoin s'effondre elle
perd 30% de sa valeur en quelques mots
on peut difficilement pour l'instant
parler de crash vous avez quelque chose
est monté jusqu'à 60 mille euros et qui
est redescendu à 30 mais ça vaut encore
30 millions au plus un marché est petit
plus évidemment il est il est sujet à de
la volatilité
c'est la vie d'un actif comme comme
bitcoin que de subir ce genre de crash
on essaie de vendre ça comme quelque
chose de tout à fait tranquille et qui
ne peut que monter non ça 200 bourses
hommes mais comme tout je rappelle que
dans le monde il ya presque un milliard
de personnes qui ont vu en 2020 leurs
monnaies nationales se dépréciait de
plus de 20%
effectivement c'est une ça peut être une
monnaie d'échangé pour ces gens là donc
la monnaie est ce qu'elle fait en
l'occurrence si les gens s'en servent
comme une monnaie il faudra l'accepter
[Musique]
m
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux ans et demi plus tard vous vous
imposez comme un espoir français du
tennis fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris est vrai que le
sport m'a toujours sauver le tennis
c'est que c'est mon sport
bon il ya un fauteuil mais je vais
essayer en fait je me suis rendu compte
que ça allait c'était suffisamment
physique pour moi j'ai une vie de
sportif de haut niveau je m'entraîne
tous les jours c'est devenu ma vie la
raison de me lever le matin j'avais
toujours ce vieux rêve de petite fille
de faire du sport de ma vie est
finalement là c'est c'est ce que je
réalise avec le jambon moi j'ai un autre
combat on ma vie qui est celui de la
sécurité routière il s'agit d'un projet
de loi qui vise à mettre en place des
tests d'aptitude pour tous les
conducteurs pas seulement les seniors on
a un contrôle technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit doit imposer
loi sur ce sujet là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petit coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la veille d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent là l on
soit vient des lignes aujourd'hui une
gauche l'extrême
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
21h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez la cour
des comptes de l'union européenne a
publié lundi un rapport sur l'efficacité
de l' agence de surveillance des
frontières frontex
un audit qui pointe de nombreuses
faiblesses autour des actions de lagence
plus de précision avec julien duroux
créée en 2004 afin de surveiller les
frontières de l'union européenne frontex
prend un peu plus d'ampleur chaque année
d'ici 2027
elle devrait devenir l' agence
européenne dotée du plus gros budget une
croissance exponentielle qui a poussé la
cour des comptes de l'union européenne a
effectué un rapport sur les activités de
frontex
selon la cour des comptes
frontex est inefficace et incompétente
pour assumer ses missions actuelles
jugées trop nombreuses outre la
surveillance des frontières
lagence doit aussi aider les états à
gérer l'ensemble des crimes
transfrontaliers
ces missions n'ont d'ailleurs fait
l'objet d'aucune étude afin de vérifier
leur impact
le rapport dénonce aussi le manque de
transparence sur le coût de ces
opérations
autre incohérence pointée par le rapport
l'augmentation des ressources allouées à
frontex approuvé par la commission et le
conseil européens alors que les besoins
n'avait pas encore été quantifiée ses
lacunes ne serait pas totalement lié à
frontex
le rapport fustige également les états
membres pour leur manque de coopération
notamment à cause du manque
d'informations fournies
[Musique]
conscient de ses lacunes
frontex est dit prêt à améliorer son
fonctionnement cependant la tempête est
loin d'être apaisé un nouveau rapport
devrait être publié à la rentrée sur les
refoulements et légaux et pour en parler
nous sommes avec françois poule et
mathis un journaliste spécialiste des
institutions européennes bonsoir
françois pour les mathis merci d'être
avec nous la cour des comptes un qui a
qualifié lagence d'inefficace dans ses
missions d'incompétente les mots sont
durs
tout d'abord françois ça dit quoi sur
les institutions européennes a dit une
chose de manière très évidente c'est que
cette agence a été créé un peu dans la
précipitation avec à cause de la
pression migratoire
mais cette agence elle a grandi trop
vite elle n'était pas mûre
elle n'avait pas les capacités réelles
pour effectuer sa mission pourquoi et
bien tout simplement parce que l'europe
n'est pas un pays
l'europe est un ensemble de 27 pays or
on demande à l' agence de contrôle d'une
part le problème de l'immigration qui
est un énorme problème mais aussi la
criminalité transfrontalière
on sait très bien les crimes n'ont pas
de frontières les criminels n'ont pas de
frontières et la pression migratoire
elle est partout elle est seule non
seulement à l'est mais elle est aussi à
l'ouest elle est à la fois sur le
domaine maritime
elle est à la fois sur le domaine
terrestre donc cessons des tâches très
complexes pour lesquels les
fonctionnaires qui je le rappelle sont
des fonctionnaires détachés de leurs
administrations nationales pour
lesquelles ces fonctionnaires n'ont pas
été véritablement préparé dans des
délais corrects
donc on efface effectivement à une crise
de croissance d'une vrai que pile de
croissance l'europe n'étant pas api
honda une agence on a finalement des
gardes-frontières et garde-côtes qui
devrait faire partie d'un ensemble qui
est fédéral or l'europe n'est pas
fédéral
là que réside le principal malaise
finalement de cette agence qui
actuellement effectivement n'a pas les
moyens dit pas forcément les moyens
matériels mais n'a pas les moyens en
véritable coopération des états pour
effectuer ses missions
et il ya surtout une domaine dans lequel
effectivement le problème est grave
c'est qu'il ya actuellement un manque
évident de collaboration des 27 pays
membres pour partager leurs données
comment une agence de gardes-frontières
garde-côtes peut-elle fonctionner
normalement
si on ne partage pas ces données or
c'est bien ce qui se passe et c'est là
véritablement à des problèmes majeurs de
cette croissance qui est encore très
défaillante de l'agencé frontex
ça veut dire que cette agence malgré ses
moyens quand même colossaux on en
reparlera elle doit gérer un problème
qui est plus grand qu'elle si j'ose dire
qu'ils qui est ingérable
à ce niveau là en tout cas de l'europe
en théorie il pourrait être gérable à
condition que les états membres qui
participent à cette agence frontex
accepte finalement de véritablement
partager leurs moyens mais pas seulement
leurs moyens humains mais leurs moyens
en matière d'information l'information
est quelque chose d'essentiel pour
l'efficacité de frontex frontex
c'est finalement une agence dont les
fonctionnaires enregistre régulièrement
aux frontières notamment les demandeurs
d'asile pour prendre exactement leur
identité etc
mais c'est aussi on lui a demandé c'est
une surcharge de travail
effectivement de s'attaquer à la
criminalité organisée à criminalité
transfrontière et on sait très bien les
criminels internationaux ne connaissent
pas les frontières
or visiblement c'est une tâche qui
dépassaient les capacités actuelles de
frontex est donc là c'est un véritable
problème
il y a une véritable question à se poser
est ce que il faut faire un bond en
avant en matière c'est un domaine
régalien je le sais bien
mais dans ce domaine si les européens
considèrent que les problèmes
d'immigration et les problèmes de
criminalité sont essentiels ce qui
apparaît d'ailleurs dans les sondages et
bien dans ce cas là il faut en tirer les
conséquences et les conséquences
effectivement
de faire un saut dans la délégation de
pouvoirs vers des pouvoirs d'une d'une
agence qui actuellement ne les a pas
clairement le rapport pointe un frontex
n'offrent pas encore aux états membres
un soutien suffisant dans la gestion des
frontières extérieures de lieux ça veut
dire qu'actuellement les frontières
européennes ne sont pas si bien protégé
effectivement elles ne sont pas toujours
bien protégés et surtout je compte les
différents pays européens ont des
attitudes différentes que ce soit au
niveau de l'immigration que ce soit au
niveau de la gestion le frontier un pays
par exemple comme la hongrie ne
participe pas vraiment au programme
frontex dans la mesure où il considère
que d'une façon il ne se sent pas
solidaires de l'action européenne en
matière d'immigration et donc dès le
moment où les pays entre eux ne
s'accorde pas sur un minimum de règles
et surtout de partage d'informations
effectivement on s'expose à cette
question autre exemple récent celui du
maroc où finalement l'union européenne
presse l'espagne effectivement de mettre
en oeuvre les moyens de l'agencé frontex
pour effectivement gérer cette question
de pression marocaine où les banques
fait pression effectivement avec ces
émigrés qui arrive à cieutat de
notamment et bien là aussi l'espagne
hésite finalement à transférer à l'
agence frontex tous les moyens qui lui
sera nécessaire dans la mesure où
l'espagne a peur finalement qu'un
certain nombre de questions relèvent de
sa de sa souveraineté et ne peut être
partagée
voilà un des sujets qui posent un
véritable problème de fonctionnement et
qui montre à vous entendre en tout cas
une fois de plus le manque d'unité qui
règne au sein des pays de l'union
européenne il n'empêche un ils se sont
accordés sur une chaussée c'est le
budget de cette agence qui est quand
même passé de 19 millions en 2006 à 900
millions 1 par an entre 2021 et 2027 ça
veut dire quand même qu'on veut y mettre
les moyens
avec le succès voilà très mitigé qu'on
est en train de décrire quand commencer
et c'est possible autant de gâchis
d'argent alors que souvent les caisses d
etat sont vides mais s'ils devront
paradoxe c'est le grand paradoxe parce
que pratiquement toute la population
tous les européens dans leur ensemble
souhaitent effectivement avoir davantage
de moyens aux frontières de l'union
européenne pour se protéger tout le
monde le pendage mais en même temps
aujourd'hui en particulier dans tous les
pays européens on clame l'importance de
garder sa souveraineté dans un certain
nombre de domaines il ya des choses qui
ne sont pas compatibles on peut pas
avoir le beurre et l'argent du beurre
dès le moment où on considère qu'il n'ya
une action collective à mener pour le
contrôle de l'immigration pour le
contrôle de la grande criminalité et
qu'il faut mettre dans ce cas là des
moyens en commun non seulement des
moyens il s'agit pas seulement d'argent
mais les moyens aussi de l'information
j'insiste sur le fait de l'information
les systèmes de chaque pays sont jaloux
finalement de leurs prérogatives
effectivement hésitent à partager leurs
informations
on ne peut pas continuer éternellement
comme ça si on veut si on veut une
véritable agence d'une part de frontier
un garde-côte comme il existe par
exemple aux états unis ben pour rendre
les moyens et ses moyens actuellement
suppose effectivement un bon dans
l'abandon de souveraineté échec c'est là
la difficulté
merci beaucoup françois problématise
d'avoir été avec nous nous avoir apporté
votre analyse
dans l'actualité également semaine
décisive pour l'indemnisation des
victimes dans l'explosion rue de trévise
à paris après le drame qui a fait quatre
morts dans le 2e arrondissement janvier
une réunion est organisée au ministère
de la justice demain on en parle avec
leila sarah la date du 12 janvier 2019
loin d'être oublié l'explosion rue de
trévise qui a fait quatre morts des
dizaines de blessés et plusieurs
centaines de sinistrés est aujourd'hui
au coeur des débats
une nouvelle réunion est organisée ce
jeudi au ministère de la justice sur
l'indemnisation des victimes qui n'ont
pas été conviés pour chaque pas qu'on
fait pour pour se reconstruire
on fait deux pas en arrière dès qu'on a
affaire à eux c'est des démarches
continuelle c'est toutes les semaines
c'est décédé absence de réponse a
parfois des douzaines de mails et cet
immobilisme
il devient insupportable ça patauge en
fait on a l'impression que chacun se
refilent la patate chaude si on peut
dire les choses comme ça aujourd'hui
enfin les avocats ont déposé un référé
pour
que grdf soit aussi me
en accusation enfin qu'on ne voit là
soit aussi mis en examen
parce que il ya l'effet du gaz qui a
c'est l'effet du gaz qui qui a créé et
qui a fait ses dégâts la seule la ville
de paris et les assureurs sont invités à
débattre place vendôme
il sera question d'une convention
appelée accord-cadre si elle permettrait
une indemnisation amiable intégrale et
rapide des préjudices de toutes les
victimes
elle est loin de faire l'unanimité la
maire du 9e arrondissement
delphine bürkli à elle choisi son camp
on avance petit à petit pour reconnaître
les victimes et moi ce que je souhaite
et c'est mon combat depuis deux ans
vraiment c'est que les victimes de
trévise soit des victimes comme les
autres et qu'elles soient traités comme
tels voilà ce sont des victimes d'un
accident collectif d'une ampleur
incroyable on va pas attendre la fin des
procédures judiciaires qui vont
peut-être durer cinq dix quinze ans pour
qu'il obtienne réparation de leur côté
les associations pousse un cri d' alerte
dans une lettre envoyée vendredi aux
principaux acteurs du dossier
nous attendons depuis des mois la
signature d'un accord cadre de l' objet
l'indemnisation des victimes
nous souhaitons prendre part à la
réunion du 10 juin
si nous ne sommes pas conviés nous ne
participerons à aucune réunion à
l'avenir à ce stade une information
judiciaire est toujours en cours pour
déterminer les responsabilités pénales
de ce drame
la mairie de paris et le syndic de
l'immeuble devant lequel s'est produite
l'explosion ont été mis en examen en
septembre 2020 pour homicides et
blessures involontaires
si la tenue d'un procès ne se profile
pas avant des années
la question des indemnisations peut se
traiter sans attendre l'issue judiciaire
et pour en parler nous sommes avec linda
zaourar président de l'association des
victimes et rescapés de la rue de
trévise bonsoir madame merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france une réunion
qui est donc organisée ce jeudi entre la
ville de paris et les assureurs sur
l'indemnisation des victimes mais sans
les principaux intéressés les victimes
elles-mêmes comment vous l'expliquez
honnêtement aucune explication par
rapport à 7
cette absence d'invitation nous n'avons
pas été conviés
29 mois que
nous faisons un point tous les mois nous
sommes invités pour faire le point tout
le monde a connaissance de la situation
des victimes de l'explosion
malheureusement il n'y a aucune action
si ce n'est oui on est convié pour faire
le point mais pour une réunion
stratégique comme celle de demain qui se
tient au ministère de la justice nous
n'avons pas été conviés n'a aucune
raison ce nous n'avons pas reçu de
réponse de la diam nous n'avons pas reçu
de réponse de la mairie de paris
concernant cette absence d'invitation
enfin d'intégration à cette réunion vous
êtes quand même je me répète un les
principaux intéressés qui va vous
représenter à cette réunion et défendre
nos intérêts de personne n'y a pas
d'avocats il ya personne non c'est une
réunion qui a été organisée par l'adiaf
à la demande du premier ministre
le premier ministre parfum lorsqu'il a
envoyé un courrier à 10
nous a confirmé que une réunion se
tiendrait à la diable que derrière les
associations seraient conviés sauf que
là il en est autrement la dia va
organiser cette réunion
grdf pardon grdf général y sera présent
la ffa aussi
la mairie de paris aussi et les
associations ne sont pas conviés
ni les avocats aujourd'hui mais d'avant
quelle est votre situation à vous mais
aussi aux autres victimes on imagine que
beaucoup d'entre vous ont tout perdu en
tout cas matériellement parlant mais on
imagine le traumatisme que ça doit être
de perdre voilà son appartement son
immeuble entier alors pour un effet pour
les riverains c'est une situation
catastrophique pour les victimes
blessées
devenue handicapée si une situation
dramatique
aujourd'hui des personnes se bat pour
retrouver pour retrouver au moins
enfin les un état de santé si je veux
dire pour eux pour la possibilité de se
mettre debout
je prends le cas des quatre grièvement
blessé à mort approche
inès angela il incite actuellement au
bloc pour vous dis enfin est
actuellement box r est actuellement
hospitalisé
donc toujours pour les blessures suite
suite à l'explosion elle a perdu l usage
de ses jambes
angela pareil a perdu l'usagé de sa
jambe à mort a été grièvement blessée
devenue handicapée a perdu l'usagé de
son oeil de son bras gauche et de sa
main et un proche a été éventrée plus
une opération niveau de l'oso fage donc
des opérations très très lourde des
séquelles très l'autre et j'ai aussi
bien sûr une pensée pour luis miguel qui
a perdu son épouse laura qui est décédé
qui est décédé le 12 janvier à aux trois
orphelins notamment à l'aîné qui bien
sûr sa mère lui manque lui manque
beaucoup il ya un manque donc toutes ces
personnes
et toutes les autres victimes bien sûr
blessés les touristes présents
toutes ces personnes n'ont pas été
reconnues victimes aujourd'hui elle se
bat au quotidien soit pour retrouver un
minimum de deux de santé physique entre
guillemets même si elles ne retrouveront
jamais lusage dvd des mains des fins des
légendes du bras pour pour amant mais
mais il n'y a pas de reconnaissance
aujourd'hui aucune reconnaissance
donc elle se bat on se bat et ce mépris
ne fait 4 pardonnez moi madame aucune
reconnaissance met donc aucune
indemnisation pour le moment deux ans et
demi après à aucune indemnisation il n'y
a pas on n'a même pas de reconnaissance
en tant que victime
enfin ce qui ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'on a un assureur s'est positionné dès
le 12 janvier qui est l'assureur
generali qui est l'assureur de
l'immeuble du 6 rue de trévise
aujourd'hui il est seul donc forcément
tout est enfin là la moindre provisions
si je veux si on peut appeler ça une
provision c'est plus une avance de frais
les victimes justifiée par des devis des
devis pour obtenir des soins parce
qu'aujourd'hui tout ce qui est chirurgie
et serra réparatrice puisque c'est des
opérations très lourde de mieux
forcément à des devis
de l'ap-hp des services hospitaliers
hospitalier oui et il faut une prise en
charge et generali ne me verse des
provisions que sur par le biais de deux
devis aujourd'hui vous vous envisager
une action en justice si aucun accord
d'indemnisation n'est trouvée notamment
demain pour vous irez clairement en
justice demander des comptes
alors on ira en tout cas nous nous
sommes fin les victimes sont françaises
elles sont européennes
on a des délais des touristes qui
étaient présents le 12 janvier qu'ils
ont et qu'ils sont victimes aussi nous
nous saisit enfin oui il y aura la
saisine de la cour européenne des droits
de l'homme oui mais ce que nous avons
interpellé l'état nous avons à faire
interpeller le président de la
république nous avons interpellé la
mairie de paris
personne ne peut rien pour les victimes
présentent le 12 janvier 2019 donc nous
n'avons pas d'autre choix si on pense
aux orphelins si on perd on pense aux
autres en vous handicapez on peut
survivre 1 on ne peut pas laisser
aujourd'hui les victimes dans cette
situation clairement pour vous
aujourd'hui à un responsable identifié à
vos yeux
dans ce drame j'ai envie de dire
l'instruction suit son cours maintenant
la mairie a été mise en examen
sur ce dossier donc forcément la mairie
doit être un moment enfin on a besoin
d'acteurs on a besoin de gens autour
d'eux qu'ils se mettent autour d'une
table et qui pense aux victimes au drame
et non pas aux et non pas au parti parce
que là aujourd'hui c'est un problème fin
on est on est honnêtement ballotté entre
entre les politiques
enfin c'est vraiment le cas c'est une
affaire politique
merci beaucoup madame les victimes n'ont
rien à faire dans une affaire politique
évidemment merci beaucoup aux linda
howard avoir été avec nous en direct sur
rt france pour percer vous pour ce
témoignage et bon courage dans le reste
de l'actualité l'algérie face à un
tournant politique les élections
législatives auront lieu samedi avec un
grand point d'interrogation concernant
la participation principal enjeu de ce
scrutin campagne marquée par la crise
sanitaire sur fond de répression du
l'irak et le mouvement de protestation
populaire françois xavier lambert des
panneaux électoraux sans affiches se
succèdent dans les rues d'alger dans la
capitale algérienne comme dans de
nombreuses autres villes
cette campagne législative ne passionne
pas la population et pour cause ce
scrutin prévu le 12 juin prochain est
boycotté par une partie de l'opposition
de son côté le irak continue de
mobiliser à alger mais aussi à paris les
opposants dénoncent un pouvoir qu'ils
jugent illégitime est la première
revendiquée revendications du peuple
algérien aujourd'hui sirat si le
démantèlement de la junte militaire mais
ne pourront pas organiser des élections
libres
pourquoi aller participer à ce pseudo
jeu pluraliste qui a été déclenchée
depuis 89 88
on a vu que la finit par la mine et la
classe politique démocratique
m à la marge les revendications
démocratiques et les droits humains en
algérie
grand favori de ces législatives le
rassemblement national démocratique qui
soutient le président algérien
malgré ce succès quasi assuré le chef de
l'état accuse le irak d'être
profondément divisée et de ne plus être
le porte-voix du peuple aujourd'hui dans
ce qui reste du irak
on trouve de tout il y en a qui crie
état islamique et d'autres qui scandent
pas d'islam les manifestants expriment
peut-être une colère mais ce n'est pas
le irak originelle c'est très
hétéroclite
initialement prévue en 2022 ces
élections anticipées apparaissent comme
une tentative du pouvoir de reprendre la
main face aux irak selon l'autorité
nationale indépendante des élections
près de 1500 listes sont en lice
le mouvement d'opposition algérien avait
dénoncé ce scrutin anticipé dès son
annonce
en dépit de nombreuses arrestations et
de poursuites judiciaires
les manifestations se poursuivent dans
les principales villes du pays
elle c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
dans quelques instants pour un journal
le point complet sur l'actualité les
jambes
[Musique]
l' oms a exhorté certains